I'm in the Botanic Gardens in Rio de
Janeiro in Brazil and Brazil is unusual
as it's one of the few countries that is
named after a tree when the Portuguese
came first to Brazil in 1500 five
hundred years ago more than five hundred
years ago they found this tree which
they called Brazil woods and the reason
they were interested in this tree was
because inside it contains a red dye now
the tree had been known already all
relatives you could find it in Asia but
it was very expensive and here in Brazil
there were huge numbers of these trees
and they started a whole industry
shipping these the wood across to Europe
and it was so valuable that there were
pirates who tried to capture the ships
and so on but by the 18th century they'd
cut down so many trees that it was
becoming rare and the industry was
collapsing and the dye inside is now
called Brazil in you can't see anything
inside this tree there's some nice other
plants growing on it looks really quite
decorative but if we go over here
I found another tree where you can see
inside I'm not sure whether this is
natural or whether it just grew like
this but you can see here the red colour
to get it out they used to grind the
tree up essentially to make sawdust and
then after that it was extracted often
with an inorganic salt like alum which
is a mixed aluminum salt with another
metal the dye is not a terribly
complicated molecule it has a couple of
benzene rings and some another ring in
the middle and it now has a more boring
name natural red 24 but it's the sort of
dye that is known as a lake dye
what that means is that when you died
cloth it doesn't react with the fiber
but you have to use some sort of
inorganic material which precipitates
and the dye is absorbed on the surface
these are the sort of dyes which when
you wash the clothes the color sometimes
comes out and depending on the chemical
you use to precipitate it so the color
changes slightly so it can be red or a
bit purple but I think that originally
one of the major uses was to die velvet
and because it was a luxury buy cloth
and so you have a luxury dye to go with
it nice red velvet you can imagine me in
the red velvet jacket so I think this
tree has two very important points for
us in the 21st century it makes a
valuable product this dye but there
isn't enough trees to make dye to
satisfy the demand so one needs to make
this dye chemically so you can get the
same material but without cutting down
the trees the trees are now quite well
preserved you have to get special
permission to cut one down and here it
is like in a museum in the Botanic
Gardens but there's another problem that
the wood from this tree is very good for
making the boughs of violins so you
imagine me playing a violin with a bowl
made of this wood and the properties of
woods differ from one tree to another
and we still don't really understand how
to make materials that have the same
properties of some woods so what this
tree reminds us is that there's still a
lot for chemists to learn how to make
materials with the properties we want
but it's still a very nice tree as well
this is just one tree in a huge country
and the rain forest still has many
species that have been been
le catalogued let alone looking at the
chemicals that come out of these trees
and it's very important before all the
trees are cut down that we find out what
the chemicals are because they could be
so valuable as pharmaceuticals ores new
dyes or molecules with new properties
and in fact I'm already understanding
that much of Brazilian chemistry the
chemistry done by chemists here in
Brazil is focused on looking and
understanding these natural products
that come from this huge richness of
plants that grow in this country
I was taking a picture because my wife
is very interested in plants and
unfortunately she couldn't come here so
I've taken a picture to show her the
treat